bonjour est dite value dont bonjour
monsieur carouge et bonjour aux
auditeurs et auditrices de martinique la
première tête de liste donc de
basse-pointe unis pour ces élections
municipales et communautaires alors la
particularité c'est que à basse-pointe
il y à peu il ya eu une élection
municipale partielle
alors vous n'étiez pas tête de liste
vous étiez sur une liste dont patrick
marier l'eau était à la tête
et puis qu'est-ce qui explique que cette
fois là bas vous ayez décidé de conduire
cette liste et d'être donc candidat pour
cette élection municipale alors la
première chose en 2019 j'avais annoncé
que je n'étais pas prête et que depuis
2014 je me préparais pour 2020 parce
qu'il faut aussi organiser sa vie
personnelle il faut organiser sa
carrière il faut organiser aussi son
espace je dirais personnel et puis santé
donc aujourd'hui je suis prête et ce
n'est pas une surprise pour les
personnes qui sont qui ont été
d'ailleurs en 2019
concernant ma candidature en tant que
tête de liste sur la commune de basse
pointe pour les élections de mars 2020
alors quelques mots justement sur cette
liste par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
et la liste sur laquelle vous figuriez
justement il y à peine un an
est ce qu'il ya une différence est ce
que la liste c'est exactement la même et
sauf que la tête a changé ou es ce que
vous avez dans la liste les flux non
halal à la liste elle est renouvelée
parce que vous pensez bien que si cette
liste qui est allé
nous sommes allés avec cette
configuration en 2019
nous n'avons pas gagné s'il ya quelque
chose qui n'a pas fonctionné donc on ne
peut pas garder la même liste bien
entendu j'ai
j'ai revu les choses parce qu'il faut
entendre aussi et commentaires des
électeurs 1 et donc et puis aussi des
déçus des gens qui n'ont pas souhaité
poursuivre parce que la vie politique
c'est beaucoup de contraintes
quand on à l'énergie de l'enthousiaste
quand on est passionné on y va et quand
vous êtes amené à vivre un échec
rien ne dit que vous avez la capacité de
pouvoir rebondir donc en tous les cas
c'est les personnes de bonne volonté
c'est des personnes qui s'engagent c'est
des personnes qui aiment bas soit comme
moi j'aime ma soit même c'est tout le
monde n'habite pas basse-pointe tout le
monde aime bassecourt a fait sont la
plupart sont originaires ou ont des
liens très forts avec bastos tout à fait
tout à fait et les personnes qui ne va
dire qu'ils ne résident pas on va dire
24 heures sur 24 sur ba soit ils
viennent quand même le week-end ils ont
résidence principale parce que ce sont
des raisons économiques qui sont aller
habiter ailleurs et puis aujourd'hui la
martinique est tellement embouteillée
bon c'est compliqué de remonter tous les
soirs mais ceci étant dit ce sont des
vrais points 3 et je pense qu'il faut
aussi permettre à tout un chacun de
s'investir à cette campagne
alors il dit vellaye ou dont on rappelle
donc basse-pointe unis mais c'est pas il
ya un slogan pour ainsi dire qui suit
cette appellation basse-pointe unis pour
la reconstruction à ce que ça veut dire
que basse-pointe a été déconstruit en
quelque sorte je sais pas moi toutes ces
destructions
alors bien sûr puisque je pense qu'on a
fait suffisamment la une des médias on a
une école qui était quand même un
collège tout le monde s'y attachaient
qu'était la maison des associations avec
a été démoli on a un président qui a été
démoli on a une église qui a subi les
intempéries et pour lesquelles on a du
mal à pouvoir trouver les fonds
nécessaires pour pouvoir reconstruire
dans les temps parce que ça sadio quand
même depuis plus de 14 ans et pas c'est
pas quelque chose qui date de dix mois
on nous constatons aussi beaucoup de
maisons qui sont en indivision qui se
dégradent parce qu on est quand même
comme jeudi dans un pays tropical et les
intempéries dégrade deux fois plus les
maisons
donc c'est reconstruire basse pointe sur
trois niveaux le niveau économique le
niveau urbanisme et puis aussi le niveau
population alors dites moi
de ce point de vue là quel est le regard
que vous posez sur parce que la maire
sortante a été quand même assez
critiquée notamment par vous par
l'opposition et donc quel regard global
vous posez sur cette mandature en
quelques secondes parce qu'il nous faut
parler également de votre proposition
phare fait je pense que cette cette
mandature est là elle a généré beaucoup
beaucoup de déception parce que on avait
mis beaucoup d'espoir en tous les cas
tous ceux qui ont voté et qui ont
reconduit l'essai en mars 2016 2019
il y a encore de la ya de la déception
donc je crois que beaucoup de promesses
n'ont pas été tenues
beaucoup de de turbulences au sein même
de son équipe
et puis vous avez toute une vie
associative qui s'est effondré donc tout
ce qui faisait le charme et la beauté de
basse pointe au delà des bâtiments
c'était cette vie cette vie familiale et
cette vie convivial que l'on avait alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez de
symbolique à la population pointoise
pour la convaincre de venir d'abord de
façon symbolique il faut que la paix
revienne à bas soit on est nous sommes
trop divisé les familles sont divisées
et
et du coup la politique se retrouve
disais quand vous êtes divisés vous
n'allez pas bien loin quand on est
plusieurs on va beaucoup plus à l'aise
par quoi voilà ce par quoi il faut
qu'elle mesure concrète à la fin de la
mesure concrète c'est d'abord
redynamiser la vie associative
ensuite vous avez un urbanisme va
pouvoir revisiter et surtout la
dynamique économique
je pense que pour pouvoir générer de la
richesse il faut crier de l'emploi
l'emploi ce n'est pas créer des
structures avec 20 employés sonny pas ça
c'est permettre à des petites structures
de se remettre en place
et puis c'est surtout je crois ce qui
est important au comice qualité doit
créer des conditions favorables mais pas
la municipalité en creux de la colonne
vous avez raison doit créer des
conditions favorables en particulier à
pouvoir mettre en place la zone franche
pour que nous puissions le grand nom
permettre un développement économique de
cette zone là et puis pas lié au désert
médical
merci et d'autres dit revel a eu dont il
dit tout voilà avec un e à la fin
vela hudon d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je vous remercie à bientôt var